-You guys, there's a lot going
on in the news right now,
but instead of me
just telling you about it,
I thought it'd be nice
to give you the chance
to decide what we talk about.
That's right, it's time
for "You Pick the Joke."
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Joke ♪
♪ Ha ha ha ha ♪
♪ You Pick the Joke ♪
-So, here's how it works --
I'm going to show you
two news stories,
then you guys get to pick
which one we talk about, okay?
Alright, here we go. Let's take
a look at story number 1.
-Finland is officially
joining NATO
as the military alliance's
31st member.
-Okay.
Here's story number 2.
-A bizarre story
out of northwest Oklahoma City.
A woman was trying
to break into a home.
She gets stuck in a chimney
[ Laughter ]
and it turns out she was
not wearing any clothing.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
Which story do you want
to talk about, 1 or 2?
-[ Bellowing ]
2!
-Good choice.
Good choice.
That's right, a woman got stuck
in a chimney, naked.
It sounds like Mary Poppins
got an OnlyFans.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Let's do another pair
of stories.
Once again,
you guys get to pick.
Here's story number 1.
-The U.S. housing market split
in two.
Prices are falling on one side
of the country,
still holding in there
on the other.
-Okay,
and here's story number 2.
-Police say that a man went
to extremes
to avoid capture after breaking
into a home in Florida.
They actually found him
in the attic,
buried in the insulation,
with his face
against the air duct system
to breathe fresh air.
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-Which one you want to talk
about, 1 or 2?
-2!
-That's right,
a burglar tried to hide himself
by burying himself
under insulation.
This is also what it looks like
when you go skiing
with Gwyneth Paltrow.
[ Laughter, ohhs, and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
Let's do one final round.
Here's story number 1.
-Gas prices could soon be
headed higher,
after OPEC+ countries
announced
a major cutback
in oil production.
-And here's story number 2.
-In Brevard County,
a ride to a job interview ends
with some charges.
A man was arrested
after allegedly going
100 miles per hour
in a 40 mile per hour zone.
He told police he had
to get his girlfriend
to a job interview
at a Taco Bell.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, which one?
Want to talk about 1?
You want to talk about 2?
-[ Bellowing ] 2!
-Let's go with 2.
Great choice.
Usually, if you hear
100 miles per hour in Taco Bell,
it's someone running
to the bathroom.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There, you guys,
that's "You Pick the Joke."
[ Cheering ]
♪ You Pick the Joke ♪